[Applause]
[Music]
so you know how to add a new key for a
car like the Honda Accord that only
requires a VCI connection but what if
all keys are lost well luckily the
process is just as simple as adding a
new key I'll take you through the
process step by step so let's get
started on this vehicle I will be using
the I M 608 Pro connect the cable to the
JVC then connect the other end of the
cable to the OBD2 port in the
vehicle establish a Bluetooth connection
to the JVC on your tablet these are the
only pieces of equipment you'll need for
this process you do not need the XP 400
Pro for this car so on your tablet tap
immo and find your car we can scan the V
automatically or find your car Honda and
input it manually in this case we are
working with a Honda 2020 Accord and the
key is a smart key push to
[Music]
start next we can do a system check to
make sure everything is working normally
this will do a system scan of all
modules that affect the keys and
security
[Music]
the scan comes up normal so let's select
all keys lost guided
[Music]
we need to turn the ignition on and off
a few times follow the prompts on the
screen we have to make sure one original
key is in the
car is this a new model newer than 2020
[Music]
yes so now we can see that a key has
been added successfully
now once it's successful we need to
synchronize the key information with the
car we do this by turning the ignition
on and off a few times
[Music]
okay so we have successfully added a key
with all keys lost now we can check to
make sure if the key works by turning
the car on or unlocking and locking the
doors so let's do that real
[Music]
quick now that we're finished we can go
back to imemo learning and check to see
how many keys we have have we can delete
some keys add a key and check key
information my name is Mike and that's
all for the Honda Accord the process
takes less than 5 minutes if you're
interested in learning all about Keys
lost for Mercedes check out our other
video in this series and if you have any
trouble at all watch our training videos
on YouTube or contact autel support